THIS WEEK IN CHESS
AMERICA IS MAKING A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO BUY TOP FOREIGN CHESS
PLAYERS IN AN ATTEMPT TO WIN
NEXT YEAR'S CHESS OLYMPIAD GOLD
MEDAL FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN DECADES.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE UNITED STATES
IS BUYING UP NERDS, NERD
MERCENARIES, "NERDCENARIES."
FOR MORE WE WELCOME BACK OUR
SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MR. TREVOR NOAH.
TREVOR! A PLEASURE!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jon: VERY DELIGHTED TO
HAVE YOU HERE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JON.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE
BACK HERE TO TALK ABOUT CHESS.
THE GAME OF KINGS, SMART
CHECKERS
( SNORING )
BLACK AND WHITE HORSEY SQUARES.
THE HISTORY OF CHESS STRETCHES
BACK CENTURIES -- OH, COME ON,
JON, JON!
>> Jon: WHAT, IS THAT, WHAT --
I'M SORRY.
>> COME ON.
>> Jon: I'M SORRY, I JUST, WOW,
I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T REALIZE HOW
BORING CHESS WAS UNTIL SOMEONE
ELSE STARTED TALKING ABOUT IT.
ALL RIGHT.
>> I MEAN, LOOK, IF AMERICANS
ARE SO BORED BY CHESS THEN WHY
ARE YOU STEALING EVERYONE
ELSE'S PLAYERS?
>> Jon: WE WOULD LIKE TO
WIN. WE WOULD LIKE TO WIN.
I MEAN, LET'S FACE FACTS.
WE COULD PATIENTLY BUILD A
HOME-GROWN CHESS TEAM THROUGH
YEARS OF HARD WORK, BUT YEARS OF
HARD WORK.
WE'D RATHER JUST BUY THEM.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, JON, DOES
AMERICA REALLY NEED TO BE THE
BEST AT EVERYTHING?
I MEAN, YOU ALREADY DOMINATE
WORLD IN ECONOMICS, MILITARY
POWER, OBESITY.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: WELL, YOU'RE VERY KIND.
WE HAVE THE MOST DAKOTAS.
>> YOU'VE GOT SO MANY DAKOTAS!
>> Jon: YES.
>> YOU'VE GOT WHAT IS IT? NORTH,
SOUTH --
>> Jon: NORTH SOUTH --
>> FANNING, JOHNSON.
>> Jon: YES.
>> LEAVE SOME DAKOTAS FOR THE
REST OF US!
>> Jon: IT IS NOT LIKE
AMERICA HAS NOT HAD CHESS GREATS
OF ITS OWN.
YOU HAD, UH, WHAT WAS THAT
MOVIE.
BOBBY FISCHER.
>> YEAH, BUT THAT WAS WHAT, 40
YEARS AGO?
>> Jon: NO, I JUST RENTED
IT.
IT WAS-- AND DEEP BLUE, THE IBM
CHESS COMPUTER.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE THE PARTS
CAME FROM CHINA.
>> ALL RIGHT, TREV, WHAT IF WE
DON'T BUY PLAYERS?
WHAT IF WE DON'T BUY THEM?
IT'S JUST FREE MARKET.
THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
>> NO, JON, IT'S NOT, THIS IS A
SPORT.
KIND OF.
RIGHT, THIS NOT MEANT TO BE AN
ECONOMIC TRANSACTION LIKE BUYING
A LOAF OF BREAD OR A SEAT IN
CONGRESS.
>> Jon: THAT HURTS.
>> AMERICA IS SUPPOSED TO BE ALL
ABOUT EARNING VICTORY.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT MOVIE WHERE
A GUY FROM PHILADELPHIA PUNCHED
A RUSSIAN SO HARD IT ENDED
THE COLD WAR?
WHAT IF INSTEAD OF TRAINING
ROCKY TO FIGHT IVAN DRAGO,
AMERICA JUST HIRED IVAN
DRAGO.
IT'S A WAY WORSE MOVIE.
>> Jon: THAT WOULD BE A
TOTALLY AWESOME MOVIE.
FISH OUT OF WATER, COMMUNIST IN
A CAPITALIST COUNTRY BUT LEARNS
TO LOVE AMERICA AND TEACHES HIS
LANDLORD HOW TO LOVE BORSCHT.
LIKE, THAT'S SUCH A GOOD MOVIE.
>> IT WOULD BE A GOOD MOVIE.
>> Jon: THANK YOU.
>> GET THE CAB. COME ON.
>> Jon: THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
>> IT WOULD BE, OKAY.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO THE
EMPIRE STATE BUILDING. NICE!
>> AH, I LOVE IT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, JON?
I DON'T EVEN THINK THAT THIS IS
ABOUT CHESS.
THIS IS ABOUT RUSSIA BECAUSE
WHAT'S THE ONLY THING RUSSIANS
LOVE MORE THAN FILMING THEIR OWN
CAR ACCIDENTS?
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: LAND GRABS, I
GUESS?
>> NO, JON, NO, CHESS.
THEY HAVE MORE WORLD CHAMPIONS
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
>> Jon: WHO IS THEIR
CURRENT CHAMPION?
>> WELL, OFFICIALLY, PUTIN.
I MEAN, COME ON!
WE ALL REMEMBER THAT FAMOUS
PHOTO!
>> Jon: OH!
YOU KNOW WHAT'S WEIRD?
I ALWAYS THOUGHT HE WAS ON A
REAL HORSE.
YOU DON'T LOOK BECAUSE YOU JUST
SEE THE NIPPLES.
YOU DON'T REALIZE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
BUT HERE'S MY POINT, AMERICA HAS
BEEN TRYING TO GET BACK AT
RUSSIA FOR STEALING CRIMEA, YOU
KNOW, WARRING WITH THE UKRAINE,
SUPPORTING ASSAD, YOU'VE TRIED
EVERYTHING -- SANCTIONS,
DIPLOMACY, PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE
SUBTWEETS.
NOTHING'S WORKED.
>> Jon: YES.
>> SO NOW YOU'RE TRYING TO TAKE
RUSSIA'S PLACE AS THE WORLD
CHESS SUPER POWER BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD REALLY HURT THEM
WHERE IT HURTS, RIGHT IN THE
PAWNS.
>> Jon: IT'S JUST THEY'RE --
THEY'RE JUST SO MEAN.
I JUST HATE THEM SO MUCH.
>> YEAH, BUT I UNDERSTAND, JON,
BUT IF YOU REALLY WANT TO BEAT
THEM --
>> Jon: YES!
>> YOU NEED TO DO IT THE
OLD-FASHIONED WAY.
YOU NEED TO EARN IT. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU AWE CHANCE
TO MAKE THIS WHOLE THING RIGHT
THROUGH THE ANCIENT BATTLE OF
BLACK VERSUS WHITE.
>> Jon: ENOUGH WITH THE
FERGUSON, WE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT IT.
>> NO, NO, JON, JON.
I MEAN, THROUGH THE MAGIC OF
CHESS.
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I KNOW HOW TO PLAY THE
TRADITIONAL CUTTING OF THE
WIRES.
( LAUGHTER )
I THOUGHT THEY'D GO AWAY.
BUT THEY DON'T.
>> IT'S PART OF THE MAGIC.
>> Jon: OH, THERE THEY GO.
ALL RIGHT, VERY NICE.
ALL RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, BECAUSE I'M WHITE,
I'LL GO FIRST.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: UH, ALL RIGHT.
I GUESS BECAUSE I'M JEWISH, I'LL
GO SECOND.
( LAUGHTER )
>> PAWN TO D-4.
>> Jon: OH, SNAP!
MOUSETRAP.
CHECKMATE.
U.S.A.!